shakin from the Los Angeles Times
covering the Dodgers hi bill good
morning thanks for joining us how are
you what do you remember about Larry
Walker do you remember that season when
he hit 366 with 30 homers and 30 stolen
bases I'm the greatest Canadian baseball
player of all time is boy it would be
hard to say it's not him it's not maybe
Joey Votto but I'm gonna go with Walker
is Votto gonna be a Hall of Famer when
it's all said and done that is a great
question because the composition of the
voting body changes from year to year
older guys retire they stop voting
younger guys have the ten years
necessary and covering baseball to get
in I think if Votto are on the ballot
today it would be tough because a lot of
the older voters value certain
statistics that maybe you're not as
valued as much by some of the younger
and more analytical writers and since
you have to wait five years after you
retire even to get on the ballot and
then you have 10 years going forward I
think he gets in yeah ok yeah I I saw
sort of the projections that Votto would
be on the short list of today's players
getting into the Hall of Fame we're
talking to Bill shakin in the LA Times
obviously with the Dodgers lost four in
a row the bullpen imploding here is
there a light at the end of the tunnel
here the light at the end of the tunnel
yesterday was provided by Kenley Jansen
who no one on the team had seen since he
had his heart episode in Denver he had
flown back to LA to talk to cardiologist
turns out the Dodgers got home yesterday
there was Kenley in the clubhouse
laughing and smiling in a bullpen he's
gonna do running and work out this week
there were reports that he was going to
miss four to six weeks and Kenley said I
ain't missing for weeks ain't missing
six weeks that said he still has to have
the follow-up visit with the
cardiologist but Dave Roberts and the
rest of the Dodgers are very encouraged
that whatever happened
they've taken care of it's under control
Kenley said he's probably going to have
to have
of a second heart procedure it's called
a cardiac ablation where they
essentially burn off the Troublesome
part of your heart and I don't want to
make any light of that or make it sound
like I'm a doctor certainly but as far
as heart procedures go it's pretty
reliable he had one six years ago
sometimes it comes back more often it
doesn't but when it does nobody seems to
think it'll be a problem and of course
the best thing is nobody's saying oh my
god you need to do this now
we can wait and do it after the season
can you overstate his value to this
Dodger team it increases every day they
play without him they were in Denver for
four games over the weekend in three of
the games the Dodger relievers lost the
game in the Rockies last at-bat the
fourth game the Dodger relievers blew a
lead they got home last night
Clayton Kershaw pitches eight innings
the longest game he's pitched this year
he's just terrific all they need are
three more outs mmm they've only got one
reliable reliever this year besides
Kenley Jansen that's Scott Alexander
they said Scott out to get those three
outs
Clayton Kershaw gave up four hits and
eight innings Scott Alexander gave up
four hits and two thirds of an inning
and lost the game if they don't make the
playoffs finish that sentence well I
think I'll follow under your previous
comment they'll have a pretty good
reason why you know the Dodgers under
Andrew Friedman have been very
successful at saying other than Kenley
Jansen who obviously is the best of the
best a closer the Dodgers are not going
to spend a lot of money on setup guys
they think the performance is too
volatile from year-to-year they don't
think it's a good expenditure of money
they want to go out and just turn guys
and see what they can find so last year
the Dodgers found Brandon marl basically
on the scrapheap
came up on a minor league contract had a
great year let him go Cubs signed him
for twenty million dollars the other
issue with the Dodgers this year has
been that the owners don't want to go
over the luxury tax threshold and
obviously the Dodger
payroll is high enough to where trades
for guys become a problem so there were
guys that the Dodgers might have gone
after at the trade deadline to help that
that would have kicked their payroll too
high
there were also in fairness guys that
the Dodgers went after that they just
couldn't agree on the trade on or
ultimately there were guys like Kelvin
Herrera and Washington or I saw Glacius
and Cincinnati where the teams didn't
trade the players anyway they kept them
but certainly it's it's hard to have a
weakness and have ownership sigh one
hand behind your back of the trade
deadline we were talking about what's
happening with the Cardinals with Matt
Carpenter and the fact he's leading the
National Egon homeruns MVP candidate but
you know that the team doesn't make the
playoffs you know handicap the MVP race
because I you know you're bringing in
Scherzer now because it feels like
there's a lack of candidates here Javy
Baez to me would be more of a MVP
candidate with what he's done for the
Cubs than Matt Carpenter but you got to
make the playoffs I would imagine with
today's voters I don't know if I'd agree
with that and that's maybe because I
live in a land of Mike Trout but okay I
think in this day and age again as
voting body changes as it is with the
Hall of Fame voters I think voters are
more willing to take a look and say the
same thing with pitchers remember you
say you had to be a 20 game winner
okay well nobody wants 20 games anywhere
you got to be an 18 game winner but
there are guys who you know their
win-loss record isn't that impressive
but we say well maybe wins aren't as
important as they used to be from my
point of view I think Harrier team does
is still important you know there are
people that talk about 2012 it comes
down to Miguel Cabrera versus Mike Trout
and you hear people say trout got robbed
people voted wrongly they just voted for
Cabrera because he won the Triple Crown
and JD Martinez might win the Triple
Crown this year in the American League
you know one mookie betts slump away and
we're looking at that and JD Martinez
ranks 8th in war and the argument is Oh
Mike Trout was the God of War that year
and he got gypped well I did have a vote
that year but if
you look back that year I would have
voted for Cabrera because he lifted the
Detroit Tigers it will come from behind
playoff berth he played well down the
stretch when the games matter more and I
respect people who say that shouldn't be
the primary criterion but I have a hard
time with people saying don't even look
at how the team does at all but you know
there's two votes for every city in the
National League and two votes for every
city in the American League and it makes
for a hopefully a diversity of opinion
that's not an official title for Mike
Trout the God of War is it okay all
right then
you know that's a good nickname like
he's the God of War go oh I get it
oh great all right bill thank you we
appreciate your time all right
that's bill shakin LA Times baseball
columnist covers the Dodgers for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]